if you're playing pokemon for the first
time with the release of brilliant
diamond and shining pearl or you've been
away from pokemon for a minute then this
is the video for you brilliant diamond
and shining pearl are remakes of the
original gen 4 pokemon games with some
modern quality of life tweaks and
enhancements so here we've got 14 solid
tips for those of you just starting out
your new pokemon journey hit that like
button sub to the channel and say
something nice to me in the comments
let's go
the classic tradition of choosing from
among a fire water or grass starter is
back once again in brilliant diamond and
shining pearl but the types of gems that
you're gonna face have a big impact on
your selection if you want a much easier
time choose chimchar seriously choose
the cute fire monkey this pokemon's
combination of fire and fighting type
moves will remain useful throughout
almost the entire game with only a few
exceptions when you're faced with
water-based area which in early game
shinx will easily solve piplup and
turtwig will evolve into interesting
type combinations with pip clubs
empoleon being a water steel type and
tertwig's torterra being a grass ground
but they are fairly evenly matched in
terms of trying to give yourself an
extra challenge any one of these
starters though will have their
usefulness and advantages of course and
if you prefer the look or style of a
particular starter by all means follow
your instincts but if you want to
essentially play brilliant diamond and
shining pearl on easy mode then trust me
choose chimchar
once upon a time mew was among the most
rare of all pokemon only available
through special giveaways or nefarious
game cheats nowadays though nintendo
hands out the adorable little psychic
cat a lot more readily and brilliant
diamond and shining pearl are no
exception you can claim the mythical mew
and jirachi by simply having save data
from pokemon sword shield and pokemon
let's go sword and shield will grant you
jirachi while let's go save data will
give you mew you can access both of them
fairly early though not right at the
beginning once you reach floroma town
though you will see an elderly couple
standing together in a field of flowers
to the left of the entrance talk to each
of them to receive your two free
legendary pokemon
[Music]
the core goal of pokemon besides being
the best there ever was is to catch him
which is your real test
to help you achieve this goal are the
pokeballs usually lowering a pokemon's
health to the red bar and adding a
status effect like paralysis will help
boost your chance of a pokeball
successfully capturing a wild pokemon
the problem is that as the game
progresses the type of pokemon you
encounter will be at higher levels and
are more prone to breaking out of
pokeballs thankfully you'll have the
opportunity to buy different pokeballs
later in the game as well great balls
are a good start and are the next level
beyond pokeballs but ultra balls are the
bread and butter and will double the
success rate of a standard pokeball
there are also dust balls which will
grant a times 2 success capture rate
bonus for being in caves and another
timestep bonus if the battle also takes
place at night timer balls will be more
successful the longer a battle goes on
and there are even quick balls which are
my personal favorite seriously stock up
on quick balls it makes catching for
your pokedex less of a chore and it
works really well a good portion of the
time so long as you throw the ball right
away and your party gets xp if you catch
a pokemon 2. it's a win-win
the poke is your all-purpose sinnoh
smart device complete with functions
you'll never use like a calculator but
it's also your shortcut key to hidden
machines or hms and their functions most
of those will trigger automatically when
you come to a tree branch that can be
cut or a body of water that can be
surfed and the fly function will
automatically trigger when you use your
map indicating a town that you'd like to
travel to as long as you've been there
before since other functions like the
pedometer aren't super useful unless if
you're trying to hatch some eggs you may
just want to hold r to dismiss the poke
catch rather than have a giant block
taking up your screen
at some point during your adventure
chances are you'll need to buff your
pokemon you could roam around the tall
grass for a while but after a few
minutes you'll probably have battled and
caught just about everything you can
from there instead consider visiting the
grand underground it opens up once
you've reached eterna city and spoken to
the underground man and the house next
to the pokemon center and after that
point you can drop down anytime by using
the explorer kit the pokemon and the
grand underground will consistently keep
approximate pace with your level making
them appropriate for grinding better yet
the grand underground is chock full of
pokemon you can't find anywhere else so
it's super helpful if you're looking for
a rare find or you just want to catch
them all
[Music]
speaking of grinding xp when wandering
this world you'll often find trainers
itching to do battle with you while you
can feel free to go around them if
you're in need of healing or you just
want to move on don't skip them too
often battling other trainers nets you
more experience than wild pokemon
battles and the game is generally
balanced assuming you'll be engaging
with all or at least most of the
trainers scattered around the world if
you skip too many though you might be
under-leveled and you'll just have to go
back and battle them anyway
through most of pokemon history
experience share has been a toggle and
usually only applied to one pokemon in
sword and shield and now in brilliant
diamond and shining pearl it is on by
default can't be turned off and it
impacts your whole party so even if
you're using one pokemon as your main be
sure to bring party members along who
could benefit from getting the extra
experience one good early game example
is magikarp which you can catch
relatively early with a fishing pole
like an old rod but magikarp by itself
is useless which usually meant it was
hard or tedious to level it up the
experience sharon brilliant diamond or
shining pearl will let you passively
grind it up to level 20 at which point
it becomes the much more powerful
gyarados my recommendation is to keep
your starter or a pokemon you know that
will be with you for the long haul in
your party at all times but cycle out
the last couple of slots in your party
for pokemon that you can level up
passively since getting them to evolve
also gets you closer to your ultimate
goal of completing your pokedex it's a
two birds one stone type situation
pokemon is known for many things but
quick snappy battles is not one of them
if you want to make your battles just a
little bit quicker you can toggle some
of the settings in the options menu you
can turn off battle animations and the
prompt to nickname your newly caught
pokemon as well as adjust the text speed
if you want things to move along a
little faster you can also toggle off
the prompt to change pokemon when your
opponent switches which is also a time
saver but it could put you at a
strategic disadvantage for type
match-ups and speaking of type match-ups
when you go to switch your pokemon
mid-battle you'll see their moves listed
along the right side this can be vitally
helpful because if you've encountered a
pokemon before and you have them added
to your pokedex this menu will list the
effectiveness of each move against your
current opponent pokemon and this can be
handy for planning out your next move
a few times throughout brilliant diamond
in shining pearl you'll get temporarily
partnered up with an npc this happens
early in the woods for example in eterna
forest when you're partnered with a
friend who will help keep your pokemon
healthy take advantage of this by
grinding a little extra in the area
since having that access to constant
healing means you won't have to venture
back to town to stay healthy
like some later pokemon games you can
select one special little monster to
follow you around in the overworld just
visit amity park and hearthrome to
unlock this function and then swap your
following pokemon by selecting walk
together after selecting a pokemon in
your party you can talk to your pokemon
from time to time and sometimes it might
have even found random low level items
it also gives it a slight passive boost
in combat and once your bond is strong
enough you'll see prompts in combat
noting that it might have dodged an
attack or even kept from feigning simply
due to its friendship with you
in the original diamond in pearl as well
as most early pokemon games you had to
venture back to town and visit a pokemon
center to use a pc that would let you
swap your current party with your batch
of stored pokemon now it's much simpler
because you can simply access the pc box
and swap them out anytime from anywhere
that means if you're out wandering the
wilderness or the grand underground and
you want to level up a different set of
monsters it is easy to simply switch
them out and keep playing without the
time spent going back to town
the held items mechanic lets you give
your pokemon passive buffs or emergency
healing opportunities while those are
great for battle even holding an item
that doesn't have utility in battle will
still help it become happier what's more
some pokemon only evolve by holding
items so it's best to keep your party
fully stocked with items regardless also
use an amulet coin you'll eventually
stumble upon an amulet coin in
hearthroom city's amity square having a
pokemon hold an amulet coin will double
the amount of money you get at the end
of each trainer battle this cash will
stock up quick and will go a long way in
making sure you're well stocked on
healing items like different potions
pokeballs repels and more luxury items
like high-end tms or even stylish
outfits later in the mid game
now this last one is a little extra tip
for me that might not matter too much to
beginners but it is a good thing to pay
attention to introduced in gen 3 every
pokemon now has a personality trait
known as nature which can directly
impact its stats some natures are
completely neutral but others will give
a 10 bonus to one stat and a 10
reduction to another the way that you
check this is by checking your pokemon
summary and noting which of its stats
are marked in red and which are blue red
means you get a 10 buff and blue means
you're getting a 10 reduction the idea
is to land a pokemon with a nature
boosting its most powerful stat and
reducing a stat that it doesn't use
often anyway you don't have to cherry
pick every pokemon you catch until you
get the perfect nature but for example
getting a magikarp to evolve into a
gyarados with an adamant nature will go
a long way compared to a gyarados with a
modest nature
pokemon is one of my favorite franchises
and i've sunk thousands of hours since i
was a kid so believe me when i say that
we've barely scratched the surface if
there's a guide that you would like to
see an explainer on go ahead and let me
know in the comments until next time
[Music]
you